you can't fail to be moved by a wave of
people taking part in a vote in one
sense it's democracy in its most simple
form but underneath that there was this
niggling feeling that this is not going
to go well
[Music]
[Applause]
a great many people in Catalonia want
Ethel need to be an independent country
they don't identify at all with Spain
this quest for independence which goes
back centuries and is threaded through
catalonia's history was suddenly brought
to this moment October the 1st 2017
they'd been promised this referendum a
promise that was made by the local
government in Catalonia the central
government in Madrid had promised that
the referendum would not take place the
police were there to prevent it from
happening that was a real feeling of how
exactly are they going to stop this
referenda cannot stop the people from
from voting that's just too many often
there's too many public stations yes
it's wonderful to see so many people out
there but behind all that you know it's
illegal and it's it's not going to end
well it's just gone
what is it just gone 7 o'clock here in
Barcelona we're outside of school we'll
take you through the crowds here to get
a sense of what it's like most of the
polling stations were schools word sort
of spread that the police would try to
shut them down very early in the morning
no one really knew how the day was going
to unfold though they were all there
they all knew they wanted to vote that
then they didn't know how that was going
to come to be whether the Polynesians
were going to open and they were going
to be able to just go ahead and do it
whether they were going to have to fight
for it
[Music]
the organization to make the referendum
happen was impeccable there was
incredible documentation literature
about how to bring people of all ages in
to protect the polling stations that was
very clearly spelled out and also just
how to carry out passive resistance
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's take a look at the demographic
there a bit the different people who
turned up people are determined they say
to carry out their democratic rights
which is to vote for independence you
had over a thousand polling stations and
there were 10,000 national police they
had to spread out all over Catalunya
they were moving around in groups of
about 40 so if you try to do the math
there is no way that they can make a
dent
[Music]
it was extremely tense people were just
completely sandwiched next to each other
forming a solid block
[Applause]
the police were trying to pull them away
one at a time
[Applause]
[Music]
it must be about 10 o'clock in the
morning that was the moment where I
thought this is switched now this has
become a a very volatile situation if
this seemed that we're seeing here it's
being replicated across the region then
there's going to be a problem it's going
to be a very difficult day
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've seen a heavy-handed approached by
the authorities not just here in
Barcelona but in towns that right across
the area let's move down and have a look
and see what's what's going on further
on down myself and Mark were up live
we'd spotted down the road the line of
police phantoms clearly something going
on down there so while we were live we
walked down the road and encountered
this city in
[Applause]
part of the plan of passive resistance
was not to let them leave so first they
wouldn't let police in to confiscate the
ballot boxes but if they did get in and
got the boxes they wouldn't let them
leave
potentially sort of abdun flowed a
little bit there are moments of relative
calm where everyone was just sort of
looking at each other and I each other
and then there were moments of singing
and chanting people getting in each
other's faces
[Applause]
we were mid interview with someone
explaining how this was their peaceful
democratic right to be able to vote she
was passionately explaining why she
believes that she was allowed to do what
she was doing and then
[Applause]
the whole crowd just started pushing
back so I was just being carried with
this ocean of people it's one of those
situations where you could almost take
your feet off the floor you wouldn't
fall over because if the whole crowd is
just compacted and carrying you once
they started hitting with their clubs
and the rubber bullets started dying I
was holding on to Ed the cameraman and
trying to make sure that he could keep
shooting and not bump into something
people started to force their way back
and I just held on to him and tried to
keep my eyes down for the rubber bullets
so that I wouldn't get one in the eye
[Applause]
[Music]
up until then you're thinking I need to
get some shots of this I need to get
some shots of that there's a relatively
structured thought process about what
you need then when something like that
happens that mentally kind of goes out
the window and you're just filming
what's in front of you
[Applause]
peaceful sitting by the the public here
suddenly switched on a sixpence and then
very very quickly the police managed to
move themselves out of there using I
have to say significant violence
moments later someone came up to me with
a golf ball sized rubber bullet looks
exactly like a squash ball but it's
sonic could do a lot of damage if it hit
you
[Music]
the International reaction almost
universally was very critical of the way
that central government in Madrid and
the courts in Madrid used their police
to to shut down this vote no one
expected that the police violence would
be on that level and that's saying
something given that actually almost
every country backed Madrid and Spain in
saying that this vote shouldn't go ahead
and that it was illegal and yet they
will condemn Spain for the way that they
tried to stop the vote it was completely
unjustifiable the fact that police were
ordered to do this was insanity
it was a huge misjudgment on behalf of
the central spanish government but if
you order national police to carry out
their duty they will they will do it
[Music]
the central government they were worried
about a constitutional crisis in the end
they created a crisis on their own
[Music]